parades 料等 inner city 25 rette の部分を鞘これ
くらいにしてね
今日はお前だての質問に応えていこうともみんな本当にいろんなコメントねありがとう
ございますまあいろんな質問がありましたけどまぁとりあえず
オヤジというコメントは全部シカトしました
ありがとうございます強い風コレートっまあ
神チャー大臣ならまともなことしろよ調子のってこんな動画件なる年からやめてすごい
目立つからキモいんだよ
[音楽]
フープ
ん
ああいう[ __ ]な奴俺に土下座して砂利車
入学卒業しても youtube 続けますか
まあそれが今すごい待ってるんですよね僕今井町大学生なんで大学生活中にね将来どう
しようかなと考えています
どうせいつか僕できれば続けたいんですけどもトイレしてください
3とって
アリエルあー2ねと
抜かれましたわプレストですとにかく
おかしくなってください空
ああああああ
ツンの購読
9分してしたかったん
f ゾンガーって路面取った
[音楽]
ズバリこう口に釣っ詰めるだけ月みやがれ
コーヒーこと言いながら
ロフトから飛び降りてくださいよホント何を見つけたらいい子要素イヤー
斉唱なくしゃみをしてください大丈夫でしょ
wc 4
冷蔵な臭いってなんや今日のくしゃみをギリギリ詰めると大声になる
ん
ni
はぁっ
れて豚がぁぁぁ
are you do
社長はん
ふうに入ってるからさすがに眉毛はそれないですよね
学校行ってるんでちょっと眉毛が厳しいですね何鳥をつけてかっこいいセリフを言って
最後はニコッてしてください前世なんてもんはなぁ
楽しけりゃそれでいいんだよ
何ですかいやいや何ですか何ですか何なんですか誰なんですかね卒で誰なんですか何な
んですか
3ソードデートプランを教えてください真夜中の静かに波の音が聞こえる海岸に行って
さ
ありで静かに座りながらん
波の音を聞いたりさ僕こう見えて結構なんか静かな場所が好きなんですよ
地図から暗い海の海岸の砂浜で二人で座ってるだけで僕も
はっのどちんこ下がってみてください
はい
弁で話してほしいあんまりこの日常的に富山弁をベラベラしゃべってるわけじゃない
からこうされてる時にたまにポロッと出ちゃうくらいの感じないけど
本当にたまに使うくらい長いちゃ
ハズイウエと
やっていっ
英語で言うとどうなりますか
選んだよっクソねえん申し上げにくいのですが10分の事って騒々しく感じております
よろしければ展開のほうに召されていただけませんでしょうか
また何が聞きたいことがあれば普通にコメントに動画がこれじゃあに書けばたまに動画
の中でも言うんでよかったらコメント残していってくださいではまたお会いしましょう
声優レクトタイプ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
ん